call of duty infinite warfare I mean you
both played finish the campaign's you
finish campaign did we both face
campaign I played a lot of zombies I
played multiplayer both on the beta and
want the game released Miguel conceptual
and reviewed it for us gave an 8 out of
10 yeah he's not here he's a does a lot
of freelance work for us but he's not in
the office today so i brought you on
talk about it because i think in the
office meeting you were the ones who
play the most yeah campaign i played it
yeah it's a pretty fun campaign night
time with it yeah i think we agree the
campaign is the most alluring let's jump
the campaign a little bit because that's
the one we want to talk about the most
but uh to touch on zombies I mean like
the black ops 3 the base game launched
with the noir one with Jeff Goldblum
that's pretty fun but I actually really
like the zombies zombies in space land
very 80s themed you know like neon
clothes there's the like the typical
jock with a sports Shack and on there's
the geek with his base got a bicycle
helmet on I don't know if he's it what
he's doing with that but then there's
you know it's it's you could bring down
hey David Hasselhoff and fight with you
zombies has always been like it was
talking to Brian bright well we both
went to infinity ward recently to shoot
the feature videos and Brian bright the
lead designer on zombies was saying like
they're pretty much given instructions
to know like to like make it as
different from the base game as possible
like as a break from you know the
frenetic multiplayer or just like the
serious tone of the campaign narrative
wait the zombies for a while had its own
narrative like yeah I mean it wasn't as
like it was a super subtle they're not
right he's head of this nonsense at all
exactly so I think yeah that was another
thing that got to like steer away from
which is cool yeah so this is infinity
ward's first time with zombies which is
like obviously treyarch started it but
um then Infinity Ward modern warfare 3
did survival I think then ghosts did
another mode I might be mixing those up
regardless this is infinity ward's first
time in zombies I had a lot of fun with
it it's pretty sprawling but there's
still the same strategies like even
plated like you know zombies tear down
these window boards and you want to let
the first few tear them down to get
extra money for rebuilding them and then
at the end of the round you want to try
to get a crawler like below the legs off
the zombie so he gives you more time if
he's the last one to run around
indefinitely and buy whatever weapons
you need off the walls but yeah you can
bring down David Hasselhoff if you go to
this omnibot over here I don't know if
it's gonna show it in this game play but
he the robot after you do a set amount
of challenge
launches into space comes back down with
David Hasselhoff and the robots face
looks like KITT from Knight Rider cuz
that's where David Hasselhoff is right
in space just barely yeah I don't know
where they got him like on the moon or
somewhere else but comes down he fights
with you for a while yeah it's really
fun I mean again it's pretty much just
the kitchen sink approach like what
crazy things can we do you activate
these this like even know tilt awhirl I
forget what the name of the generic name
of the ride would be but it like starts
this tornado that sucks zombies up you
can activate bumper cars you can do a
dance floor that's got like the zombies
become like they don't hurt you anymore
because they're busy dancing and then
the disco ball becomes lasers and kills
them or you if you're on the dance floor
I like that um so yeah no I mean they're
zombies again it's fun it's it's one of
my favorite ones I like it a lot and
then there's multiplayer which every
call of duty that's kind of what I
personally judge called duties by me
until like this one but you know the
multiplayer is always some massive
player base they're always gonna make a
lot of money because a lot of people
going to play them yearly release with
three development studios and they've
always iterated on multiplayer I feel
like this is the least they've done
because you play like specialist for
black ops 3 are like carried over here
in terms of in form of rigs which kind
of these like character classes
themselves but they don't factor into
the overall picture as much as I would
have hoped hmm art so what I I liked
about the campaign so much is that there
was a really cool dynamic and change of
pace like you know in one moment you're
starting a side mission you're sniping
outside of like asteroids next thing you
know you're inside the spaceship
sneaking on onboard choosing whether you
want to go stealth or not but I think
what was really neat for me that I loved
was the zero-g elements of the campaign
and I feel like if the multiplayer was
going to you know pull from the campaign
I would have liked to have seen a lot
more of that type of stuff you're like
he started like a room in the middle of
the map where they could kind of
implement these like cool changes of
pace because that was I feel like such a
such a themes to heart and soul of this
push to go to outer space let's just go
there and do that in all shapes and
fashions like in the multiplayer ever
like that was kind of missed opportunity
yeah I mean they kept showing these you
know like a big push with our art
direction was to try to combine modern
naval technology with NASA and that goes
like carries through the multiplayer
maps right there's the one map Frontier
which is like this space station that
sees like varying elevations between
these corridors and everything but yeah
like you said they don't use the space
setting to the multiplayer advantage to
make anything interesting it's just call
of duty combat like vanilla call duty
combat still feels really good it's
always gonna feel good they I think they
mastered it like I don't even know how
many years ago the movement if I hadn't
played titanfall 2 i would say it feels
good but titanfall 2 just feels so
incredibly great that call of duty kind
of feels lacking and they went all in
with they went all in with that you know
yet while running when here it was like
you could do it but like would that be
like valuable in any way no I wouldn't
like it I felt like when I wall run I
just get killed right away whereas in
titanfall at speeds me up and i can drop
on people really fast but the rig's
don't they factoring when you have your
ultimate like the perks that you I know
you hate when i call it the ultimate
like was that you yeah cuz that was
about the abilities yeah we're so easily
swayed to take on new terms what what
should what should I call it the the the
Billy you build out tourism you activate
I don't know climax what is that getting
college what did you get my next on
everyone a control that what the game
comes yeah what did it warm call it what
does the game call that thing oh geez
the rig horrible no that's titanfall
yeah I do it I haven't played much
player I wouldn't know I mean I'm just
gonna call it the ultimate that you
wouldn't actually one when you activate
your superpower each rig has two so this
is again this is another layer on top of
the pic 10 system that black ops to
introduce you pick 10 free let your
weapons your attachments your lethal
your regular or your tactical grenades
the rigs is another layer on top of that
where you get one of two like ultimate
abilities you activate whether it's a
weapon or just like shield charge for
certain characters but then you also
have three unique perks one of which you
can exit at a time so it's oh so each
rig so you'd say you pick a stalker you
can activate the one like in like stay
off radar perk but you can't use the
other two unless live part of the pic
Ted system but they don't really
factored in as much that
like they don't do enough to actually
very the call to do multiplayer formula
whereas black ops 3 introducing that
movement the movement was different
enough from advanced warfare advanced
warfare was more shifty kind of and then
black ops 3 was going for more titanfall
kind of fluid movement again this just
feels like a very small adoration of
black ops 3 like tre arcs multiplayer
that they kind of started working on
last year I know these rigs are kind of
an effort from like infinity were saying
to kind of cater to this crowd this
shooter crowd that's in like you know
increasingly getting more used to these
classes like that stem from like MOBAs
now you know that you have the term hero
shooter and like even titan falls titans
kind of do it to their character like
these classes are getting more
characterized and we're recognizable
kind of like i don't know you might seem
like a fighting game just knowing how to
counter certain characters or something
I don't feel like the multiplayer did
enough for me to really just like I'm
probably going to go back to it when I
have tight and fall and battlefield and
overwatch still with a new character
everything but yeah I think we're both
in agreement this campaign might be one
of the better call of duty campaigns in
my opinion especially since modern
warfare but I even like this more in my
work I think it takes more risk than
modern warfare did um not just because
of the story which I actually liked but
the structure of it right the seamless
structurally how did you feel about the
sack taking off from planets going to
space ships coming back down doing a
dogfight it's pretty it's really
engaging and I'll haven't looked back
that on it it makes me almost think like
cheese was the timeline of this whole
campaign like two days yeah like I think
you're just constantly not seeing that
loading screen or it's just mashed with
like really cool you know cinematic like
shots like your jackal ship jettison out
into space uh yeah like some of the
highlights of that campaign were like
again these these moments are like a
side mission an optional side mission
that you don't have to do and you're
just sneaking in and taking over a
spaceship from like outside like you
know huddling around asteroids going
upside down in zero-g like just really
unique stuff that I haven't seen in a
game like this kind of sci-fi zero-g
element like I don't know if I've ever
seen it done well enough where it's like
I don't you know I guess to a degree
believable
but it's great and the characters were
great the writing was great like a lot
of you know really great in-game
characters characterizations of people
and like development in general of
characters like handling inside the
actual gameplay which is really neat
yeah like you know what you thought was
like a battle between two characters
something happens during the guys you're
shooting and then that gets resolved and
carry on it carries on into the
cinematic in the next part and so I
totally misses what you're talking about
yeah you mentioned the next day and I
went back and play doh oh yeah I didn't
see that there might be like something
like naughty dog would do that is
exactly right yeah yeah same stuff yeah
a really cool exploration levels of the
rubber boots one level which was really
cool that it was on the mercury one um
like the power kept turning off and on
mm-hmm and it was just a really cool and
neat dynamic for a call duty game you're
exploring and you get to continually
turn your flashlight on and off I don't
know it's again for a call of duty game
which is so much as far as campaign goes
like so on Rails this felt totally not
that and that was like a really
refreshing thing to have happen yeah you
mentioned the fact that i don't know i
felt i sat down and unlike most call
duty games after playing for about two
hours I didn't feel like I played like
four missions I feel like I just played
this to our thing right that existed as
it on its own and a little weird
comparison to you and I think it made
sense though radius to Jake I said it
it's like the Birdman of video games
it's like they disguise their cuts or
loading screens in this case when you do
side missions they just like warp you to
the armory where you pick your loadout
that more p to hang or regain your
jackal but you take off yourself where
most games when you would finish a
dogfight in a jackal which we can talk
about the jackal the dogfights to it
would just end and cut to black and go
to the next mission or the cutscene this
like you actually have to land your ship
again and then you go into the like the
docking bay where you and your partner
salt her last name is Salter you like
rotates and you like have this
conversation as your ships you're still
need [ __ ] with your ships are getting
going down to the hangar bay you get out
and then you walk back up to the bridge
as like Griff the armory guys telling
you oh that blue pretty picked up will
be useful for the next mission and then
use like you go back up to the bridge
you see even
newscast of like what you're hearing was
yes frustrating you know it's like can
you have the news reporters stop ratting
out all the time how the [ __ ] did you
get this scoop like five minutes effort
as the epic is gonna see this yeah they
didn't know it's like oh they found
top-secret plans for this planet
destroying sphere that they made but
then you go back to the bridge and you
were saying like you go to the center
console and we said it reminded us of
mass effect right you pick you up this
star map and you get these side missions
it's either a jackal dogfight mission
which will improve your jackal the
starship you're using or the dog fighter
the fighter you're using for dog fights
or you will go to these like
infiltration missions which a lot of
times start in zero-g or start in your
jackal when you have to infiltrate this
battleship and then you go in and like
you put a bomb in the life-support
systems for the specific room so then
you activate it and you watch Pete the
gravity go in the action go away and
you're in it I don't want to spoil this
but there's a you know you put on
disguises you just do stealth and still
feels good reminds me the Metro games
you played those it's it's not realistic
in terms of like their sight lines and
whether they saw you or not it gives its
it's enough to like let you have fun
with the stealth and actually like kind
of crouched around and feel a little
powerful you know being in the shadows
wherever you want to say right and it's
one of those moments to it which is neat
it reminds me like a metal gear game
where it's like you are controlling your
own stealth until you messed up and it's
your option if you'd like to go go back
to a checkpoint or you just continue the
rest of the that that mission now you
know what the alarm sounded it might be
a little more difficult but that's how
it is and that's how it's gonna be and
that's very unique to [ __ ] for me you
know you think like all ghillied up like
you get spotted for the most part I
think it would reset right like yeah it
worked for me at least yeah I was more
like an early Metal Gear Solid where you
don't have much a fighting chance right
in terms of just all-out combat yeah
what did you think we touch the jackal a
few times would you think of that dog
fighting with the controls it's pretty
good I thought uh you know like I'm I'm
a huge fan of like Sims and having that
faux like Wonder one like rolling
ability it's there on the d-pad you know
you're never it felt more like a like a
tank it's a move you're hovering tank
which is fine like I enjoyed it you know
I've been a lot of starcraft or sorry
starcraft star fox kind of a reit arena
type stuff gotcha where it's like
depending on like like you're not like
flying like you know through space on
like a tangent or like a waypoint like
you just kind of like neo circling an
area that's forming swarming yeah it's
fun I enjoyed it I kind of got bored of
them like I did all the side missions at
once more or less I don't think only a
couple are given to you as you you know
finish the main campaign storyline like
you could get a one or two more but i
dinna mall at once which was kind of
boring it's yeah some some locations
seem to be repeated oh yeah it
definitely is a lot of asteroid fields
and like space stations yeah I do feel
that the jackal combat would not be as
impressive if it wasn't in a call of
duty game just cuz it's so novel for
call of duty I think I like it more for
how it fits into the overall sequence of
you know like again leaving your ship
getting into a jackal manually taking
off not kind of manually using analog
stick to like use your boobs but then
you see yourself flying out you get to
the dog fight your dog fight the
controls will feel natural to you if you
play a lot of first-person shooters
because you can just turn on a dime and
hover or just hover in place and just
shoot something there's a lock on you
still to be sort of aiming with the lock
on it just keeps your reticle around the
guy you're like the only thing you're
really trying to do is avoid lock on so
yeah you're just hitting your flares
when that when it tells you to yeah so
it just gets a little boring like you
kind of see the same thing you're you're
hitting these big excites carriers in
the same way like it gets a little
repetitive it's still spectacle like
you're getting like you know you're over
Earth you're over tighten like that's
cool game is gorgeous especially in
those cutscenes we just saw few of
honestly just there's a part where the
ship earlier I think it's your jackal
it's not the retribution the carrier but
your jackal is coming up like a bottom
left of the screen very small there's a
big asteroid just like covering the
solar flare from the song sure mercury
and just gorgeous how it outlines a ship
and everything that's like one example
but just throughout this game the
cutscenes especially and again the cut
scenes aren't the only time you're
hearing dialogue and you're seeing the
story play out there's a lot of times
like Ethan the robot me and you like
love I think everybody's gonna love
ethan who plays a gay now ethan is
nicknamed for what it is like it's like
a call sign like III and or something
new Subarus uber amicable and like he
makes these jokes I
laughing at like someone said oh you got
quite the personality yeah I had the
brain of a farmer and then some lady
[ __ ] me he's like really completely
yeah you know ma'am yeah he's he's
basically tars from interstellar but
like with with a much more like
endearing like heart filled like emotion
like hui just see you care about him
yeah you're like a brother to me uh one
thing I just remembered I haven't
brought up until now was I thought the
as you like go through armories and it
seems like you're getting Intel which
then are affecting your suit like those
I kept hearing that guy Griff wherever
say oh we got something new in the
armory go check out the armory mm-hmm
the armory was only there just to
customize a load out like you're not
doing anything with your suit though if
you press oh so if you press pause at
any point the campaign on the right side
it'll show you all the parts you've
accumulated they just their passive okay
you don't activate them they're not
purchased what was frustrating me you
stack ID I got all of them innit like
filled up the whole screen like like
faster health regen more ammo but I like
I didn't a lot of these perks I didn't
even notice you yeah they're not they
weren't something that would just be
stand out but I think if you went
through the game and played the last
mission again without getting any of
them you might notice I think it makes
it like you're gonna want those if
you're playing that so that's the thing
there's that difficulty uh should I
should I should look this up but i think
it's either this there's two more
difficulties past just veteran now which
is always like notoriously hard and call
of duty games because you're just this
massive glass can and you doing the
normal damage but you can take like one
shot for your dead I think specialist
there's one where you play through the
game until you die there's no check once
you restart the game so today I would be
interesting that would be interesting to
play that and have that risk reward of
do I go in this mission and get this
park that's gonna help me out later on
or do I just try to get through and be
super cautious or throw my ps4 out the
window do is doing me drop it and just
say [ __ ] it cuz I don't know like I
think it there's two difficulties I'm
probably mixing one up the other is just
super hard uh so I'm I don't like I'm
gonna go back and play those I play the
campaign anything I've got enough but I
was to say it like did you feel like the
idea of like you being able to like
sorry goob schuur I just chimed in yolo
mode he's right that's what it's called
yeah yeah
uh I felt that all the extra do the kind
of free roam exploration type stuff I
wouldn't even call exploration actually
but like going into your cap cabin and
being able to like you know pull up your
monitor and look at your the bios of
each character a lot of that serves a
cool purpose and it's very unique to the
game but I felt like like toward the end
like are you really checking these
things again are you checking the board
to see what one of these like hihi
commanding officers you killed that are
like kinda like you know would you call
them like like vips kills already
targets kind of some of it was like neat
and then tore the end I felt like it
just got real there's no meaning
pointless there's nothing like like to
have your armory which is something that
you get to as you start a mission a lot
of times it's like it'd be cool to have
that on the monitor I don't know I felt
like they almost they could have gone a
little bit further with like some of
that like free roaming stuff I would
have liked to have been able to like
have more customization maybe I you
could you know you get all these perks
maybe you can like choose which ones you
want on of 5 yeah I don't know so final
question you play called did he pretty
consistently over the past 13 years
since it started campaign the stories
yeah where does this one fit like rank
all right yeah this this the campaign
story is is really great mm-hmm III
don't know if I could rank it I'd say
it's just in like memory like it's like
one of my favorites as far as like
characters that you remember like well
after like it's like Ethan the sum of
those characters even like Omar like
salt like they have a lot of Appeal and
you really feel like you've come to know
them because of these really great
immersion implementations of like
constantly interacting them at you
you're playing the game and you're like
hold on it you know i'm not gonna go
kill someone i'm gonna wait and hear
what this person has to say that feels
like a choice and that's pretty neat to
see these characters grow over time uh I
am definitely excited to see if they
continue this be a trilogy whatever i'd
like to see where this goes for sure
like I wanted you know I want to know
what happened or happens after you know
the end of this game yeah I think it
would be safe to
that's gonna be a trilogy I know that
was their intent with ghosts then ghost
was wasn't that poorly received the time
like are you looking at Metacritic it's
sitting around like eight something like
despite people's bad memories of it not
innovating much of course that was like
Infinity Ward's first full game after
the departures that formed respawn
entertainment in like 2010 with Vince
Zampella Jason West leaving but this one
definitely didn't leave a bad taste in
my mouth at all I actually I'd encourage
people go try this campaign I know like
it's called duty and there's kind of
negativity surrounding that because the
annual release and people think it's
played it safe its campaign i actually
think they took really cool risks with
highly encourage people if you're a fan
of shooters definitely if you just want
like wanted to check out go see how they
do this campaign it's pretty impressive
but yeah so our view is up on gamespot
miguel concepts me on a freelancer did
it give it an eight out of ten you can
go read the full thing and watch the
video on youtube or on gamespot let us
know what you think in the comments
below